salut fabien olicard salut à vous peuple
d internet
alors là littérale on pourrait penser
qu'on a fait c'est vrai alors que ce
n'est pas moi je suis de retour sur
cette chaîne avec la merveilleuse le
vinyle est de la libye ni bonjour j'ai
fait le même la double que celui que
j'ai fait il ya un an et demi vidéo
dans cette description est gay également
vidéo sur ce petit là où je le point
toujours droit quand j'ai un doute d'où
est ce que ledit appareil moi je fais ça
je rajouter des champions qui partira
voix voilée au bon endroit
ok c'est la fin de cette vidéo merci est
justement on vient de faire une vidéo
sur ta chaîne wii qui s'affiche
également là haut et qui également dans
la description de cette vidéo 7 et une
vidéo sur le thème du mensonge on a
utilisé des cartes avec des dvd tous en
bas il y avait également un délit
des pouces en l'air et en fait ces
cartes là c'est des cartes qui ont été
créées par des potes que je cite qui
s'appelle maxime et sylvain ils ont créé
des cartes à jouer qui était toujours
avec des trucs de réseaux sociaux des
choses comme ça ok merci pour cette
créativité gérer sur débordante
donc quand on reçoit un sms il ya
toujours une bonne nouvelle ou une
mauvaise nouvelle qui se cache derrière
c'est vrai quand on voit apparaître le
logo de ce sms ne sait pas exactement on
essaye de deviner le pressenti en et
mgic oms a tenté d acquittement est
alors le deuxième constat c'est que
aujourd'hui on envoie des sms en
permanence ont un peu habile taceq
c'était un proxy est même perturbé il y
en a qui l'envoie d'essaimage entremise
ans qui est extrêmement dangereux très
dangereux ne fait pas absolument pas
d'autre pendant qu on converse qui est
extrêmement chien chien fou dangereux
aussi mec en face et un peu général qui
le prend mal eh bien on va se faire un
test autour de tout ça ok alors que moi
je vais te perturbe et en récitant les
décimales de pi parce que je crois que
c'est un faux filet si c'est vraiment il
ya j'ai deux passions dans la vie
les tacos et réciter ledesma lui dans le
sens avait conseillé la mali et donc je
vais te perturbe et toi pendant ce
temps-là tu vas d'essayer de trier ses
cartes
tu vas l'étrier mais tu vas tu vas aller
prier à l'instinct ok c'est à dire tu
vas pas te laisser je ne vais pas
regarder l'autre absent regardes et tu
vas essayer de faire comme derek se soit
fois en fait tu fais ce que tu penses
que c'est une bonne nouvelle ou d'une
mauvaise nouvelle tu vas le [ __ ] comme
ça en deux temps un poids gauche un peu
à droite un coup à droite à côté 2 6 6 3
après donc toute manière je ne peux pas
deviner puisque je n'ai aucun moyen de
savoir exactement son rôle dès que je
commence à réciter fille qui commence à
le faire au lieu de regarder tout le
temps ce que tu fais tu cherche à me
regarder en même temps c'est comme ça
que je vais perturbé en fait d'accord
comme si tu étais en voiture ou en train
de faire autre chose et tu t'occupes
étaient des sms et en gardant quand même
en toi le côté instinctif de est-ce que
je pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle ou
mauvaises
je ne céderai du parce que je vais pas
là alors je me sens prête mais il ne m'a
pas prévenue de ce qu'on allait voir son
jeune âge
j'y vais comme on dit à l'aveuglé avec
moi les lots but ok très bien
donc là je te regarde ouais moi je vais
dire 3,1 cap15 9 de 6,5
trois des 28 9 7 9 3 de 3000 4 6 2 6 4 3
3 3 de 7,9 vérifier si ces rushs de 8,4
à 9,7 à 1 6 9 3 9 9 x 7 5 1 0 ça inclut
2 097 quatre notes 4,4 gencives ou
s'élèverait ouais tout à fait mensonger
je te jure alors vérifier si je vais en
civil avaient vieilli dans les
commentaires et je me suis arrêté à 4,9
4,4 donc après ça aurait été 5,9 de 3
078 1 6 4 et ces techniques visent à
évaluer le sud
moi j'ai une petite vie d'enfer et
patience alors tu m'as fait des deux cas
comme ça oui ok on va pas encore regardé
comment ta fille et dia logue a que vous
qui allez les voir y as vous avez 7 de
smiley juste ici ok tu vas les mélanger
la samba je ne veux pas que je sache
qu'il est ou du dieu ont posé un ici
devant il ya ici devant donc là pour
l'instant eu lieu uniquement le hasard
et pas mes capacités dont vous ne jugez
pas de capacité sont peut-être futur des
capacités cacher nous dire déjà c'est id
au départ j'ai mélangé je t'ai donné
sata trier comme tu voulais en
brocardant quai sans perturber la vie
dure ledesma y est tu les a mis dans
l'ordre que tu voulais ce site voici gtc
pas regarder donc je ne vais bien je
vais juste de la qu'il y avait 18 cartes
oif
si tu as fait quelque chose d'à peu près
égal je comptais combien on
ici 2 3 4 5 6 9
c'est merveilleux ton ami 9 d'un côté et
9 de l'autre et je n'ai pas calculé jade
instinct qui a mis exactement autant à
gauche qu'à droite
j'aime beaucoup maintenant on va
découvrir ici tu nous a mis le smiley
triste widow de mauvaises nouvelles
ici le smiley qui sourit donc plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
d'accord on va voir et l'accord dans ton
prix si ça correspond pas
puisque déjà un petit peu ouf oui là ça
serait un petit peu trop là par exemple
juste en face 10 miles et qui sourit
camille un pouce en enlevant et enfin
d'hystérie après ça on va en même temps
il y avait que quatre possibilités
c'est à dire que ce soit de rouge de
bleu un rouge et un bleu dans science
ont rejoint dans l'océan sur k7 confie
je suis en train de me faire c'est de la
magie
non parce que je ne touche à rien sinon
c'est ça qui est anglais et geste ici
parce qu'il ya un smiley une enquêtrice
d'un smiley triste on peut vérifier si
aussi un petit peu on a un smiley en
l'air tous en l'air on a encore un pouce
en l'air épuisés quand on va même tout
est allé ce sera beaucoup plus simple
on a dû s'imaginer rist ici à foison et
du smiley en l'air ici à foison le la du
biniou je ne sais pas comment vous avez
fait mais d'une manière ou d'une autre
ou vous avez un instinct surpuissant ou
quelqu'un vous a manipulé en russie dans
les vies si mal depuis je ne sais pas on
ne sait pas et pour une fois le pas vous
expliquer parce que ça fait plaisir
aussi de se faire un peu bluffé sur la
chaîne je crois que je n'avais pas fait
ça depuis deux mois
vraiment pleinement mais moi j'aimerais
durant perfect tu ne vas pas l'expliquer
du tout non pas du tout non mais alors
là vraiment si vous comprenez
mettez un commentaire mais c'est un
lapin je ne comprends pas vraiment non
plus j'ai prié toute la nuit pour que ça
fonctionne
bah écoutez bien prier c'est à
fonctionner et ça fonctionne on parcourt
je gagne beaucoup de défenseurs que ça
fonctionne à ce point que ce soit un
sans faute mais pour le coup c'est un
sans faute est vrai c'est un sans faute
au delà du sans faute de quoi penses que
tu as des ressources cachées en toi que
tu connaissais pas oh oui oui on va
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo on va
rester sur cette info j'étais rappelle
que tu as aussi fait le tri exact 9 de
chaque côté à un plus bas à 1 - non mais
non bien sûr c'est moi qui suis bluffé
de toi et ça ne le sera jamais non non
mais j'aime pas ta chaine j'ai cru me
semble ridicule qu'on ne juge pas on
aurait dû terminer par ma vidéo écoutez
je propose en soutien en consolation
pour la deviner que vous laissiez ce
magnifique tous en mettez un pouce bleus
non mais arrête de belles années comme
ça où j'ai dit mot banane et ça revient
en 2018 oui mais leurs bananes et
relisant premier aujourd'hui une sa
bonne nouvelle pour les f pour les
alouettes
en fait je cherchais à mooresville pour
dire que c'était cool s'ébattent ses
batteries comme guillaume se bat
guillaume battre la référence par là
merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo merci beaucoup à lula d'une
idée peu merci à tous de m'avoir invité
mais par contre vous n'avez pas vu la
vidéo qu'on a tourné ensemble tout ce
que vous avez déjà oublié ça donc je
vous le rappelle une vidéo sur la chaîne
de lola lire dans la description n'est
pas visiter sa chaîne à vous abonner
parce que c'est en plus de ces super
chaîne est une super fille femme meuf de
ce que tu veux c'est aussi un peu dans
mon coeur ma marraine
qu'est ce que je n'aime pas bien c'est
un des rares à mériter tout ce qui lui
arrive
donc j'espère vraiment que tu ne coupera
pas c'est un montage mais tu mérite tout
ce qui est arrivé je suis très très très
fier de voir ce qui se passe pourquoi je
suis très contente et bf je ne sais plus
quoi dire du pad je suis très gêné il
était c'était l'idée déjà nature est une
d'imaginer que ce jeu aussi
embrassez vous vous même parce qu'on
n'est pas là pour le faire mais on
aimerait le faire met un petit poucet
abonnez vous et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]